Change line. This is going to be August.
I'm cool. We're still bullish, so now we're in the 1st of August.
We have Joel Thaisam, so New York based news.
There's not going to be a shift in there. The M1 is too high.
There's no way a shift in there. You can see it.
New York, going to get a little bit cautious.
No continuation there.
That would be an entry. 8.30.
Don't want to trade through.
I don't want to trade through ISM and Joel at the same time, like definitely
not.
So let's have a look.
That's 9. Why is 9 here? I've got that spike because it's in the wrong time.
Okay, awesome. Yeah, I wouldn't want to trade through that.
So it wasn't 8.30 by the way, it was 9.30, which I didn't forget to move UTC.
Cool. We're still moving in the same direction.
We're still bullish when it's in the 2nd of August.
Apparently we have no news, so we'll see how that goes.
Excuse me.
Equal lows, nice shift, any entry, nope.
New York, that's got to be an entry, surely.
No, maybe it's not.
There's no shift below there.
The question is, is what's the M1 structure like here?
That makes the data a lot better, cleaner.
There's only 3 kind of pullbacks in here, highly doubt it.
Which means we shift bearish.
Not here. Shift bearish here.
Yeah, same data.
Which means this high here is all swing high.
There's no shift there.
I can already read the price actually in the 15 minute.
You can see the 1 minute highs and lows on the 15 minute.
It's quite simple.
I know that price comes in and then it takes 15 minutes to put this low to this
high.
Which means there's probably going to be at least a 3 kind of pullback in there
.
Like good probability.
And then we break the lows.
So I know there's a break of structure in the 1 minute timeframe.
Which means that there's a good likelihood that this is the M1 swing high.
And so when you see price come in and then trade away from it, you can already
see how that looks like in the 1 minute.
Which is exactly what we looked at. It's probably a pullback in it.
Which means that's probably a break of structure.
Which means that's probably the swing high, but it respects it and trades lower
.
So you can see price action in the 15 minute.
When you have a large 15 minute, you know, when you have like a large 15 minute
price moving there,
you can already see that it doesn't matter about this price action because this
isn't going to produce a break of structure or change your character.
Unlikely, unless you maybe get something in here.
Which is used to unlikely.
So you know that there.
Right, the slow is going to probably be somewhere here.
You see it again.
Up.
Where is it?
Up here, for example, this is a little bit different, right?
Because notice that this doesn't just go straight high.
We're putting a high.
And from this 15 minute high to this 15 minute low, there could be a pullback
in there.
So that when price goes up, maybe you'll get a shift in there.
And if you go to the one minute.
You'll see it.
Right.
You'll see that from.
What is it?
This 15 minute high.
It's only a two countable back.
Sometimes you don't get them.
But then you come in here and you can see that that is a three countable back
to this high.
So we do have it.
So sometimes you might get them.
Sometimes you might not.
But you can see whether it's even worth looking, for example.
Cool.
Wednesday, Thursday, the third of August.
We have a decent amount of news on this day.
Balance of trade.
ISM.
Cool, New York.
We don't change.
We don't break structure.
We do break structure.
New York.
Possibly tradable.
But that's to change a character.
And then we have ISM and stuff.
So I'm going to trade it.
That was accidental.
I haven't missed anything.
We become bearish here.
That's become the swing high.
We become bullish here.
That's the swing high.
That's the swing low.
So we may have missed a trade in here.
But I don't think we did.
And there's no change in here.
It could be here.
Let's go and see.
But I don't think it is.
First performance is even possible.
No, there's not even a change of character that's possible.
So I don't need to go.
That's another thing.
I don't need to go and check the structure because there's not even a period of
time where price breaks through a three kind of pullback in London.
There's no three kind of pullback.
Even if, let's say, for example, this was a structure.
And then we're bearish from here.
Well, now there's no pullback here.
No pullback here.
That's not a three kind of pullback.
That's a pullback, but we don't break below it so that therefore price cannot
break above it.
Right?
So that becomes the low.
Then we trade up here.
Right.
And then that becomes potentially a break of show trick continuation.
There's no there's no possible way.
There's an entry.
So there's no point waste of my time going to check.
Is this what I'm going to show?
Because it doesn't matter.
It's not possible.
Friday, the full four of us that's going to be into the F to the P.
Which I don't want to trade.
Honestly.
Now we're going to London session.
So, for example, like now, I don't need to go and check one minute structure
because I know for an absolute certainty that there's an at least a one minute
pullback in here in here, which means that.
It may be low.
It may be higher appear the change of character, but I know for sure any M one
structure that's below this low that gets created in here, for example, I now
know that that's the M one structure that's in control.
So we break this high.
I don't even need to check this because I already know that this is the
relevant M one.
Right.
That's what I was explaining earlier.
But it's fun to just give those little pieces of game because.
Yeah, why not?
So this is Monday, the seventh of August and as far as I'm aware.
We don't actually have any news.
So we're looking for longs.
I don't think so.
Possibly, but probably not.
I can already read it.
Without having to go and check or give a price action.
I know that's the M one swing high because it can't be anything else.
Right.
If we come back here, it's obvious.
I don't need to know if there's any pullbacks in here and shift.
So I just know that, okay, anything that's really below this level that creates
new structure is the current structure.
Same thing.
I don't need to go and check if there's pullbacks in here and stuff because I
just know that anything below this level, if there's a pullback after that, it
doesn't matter.
I don't need to go and see, okay, is that a change of character because it
doesn't matter because the moment that it breaks down the low and there's
another pullback in continuation, then that's where the structures in control
from.
So it will save you so much time by just being able to do that.
To the point where I just know, okay, that's the pullback.
I don't need to check anything else.
That's the structure.
Structure leg.
So that becomes your confirmation.
Undoubtedly.
Which means your actual trade.
This is a difficult one.
Because I would like to use this.
Objectively.
This sell to buy.
This is already mitigated.
I would like to do this, but I don't know if I can because price could still
come down here.
Maybe I'll just use the 30 minute body.
Body close.
But it does add another element of risk in some sense, in some sense, so that
my, you know, I'm running a higher risk of getting stopped out.
Because it's very possible price could come over down here and continue growing
higher.
So I'll use this low. That's a low that I'm really confident that it shouldn't
get traded through.
Unless it's going to get traded through properly.
I think this is our first trade of August.
If I'm not mistaken.
Okay, we took a trade that we didn't.
We took a trade that we didn't fill out.
31st of July.
Or was that this trade right now?
Okay.
It's a long.
This was, this was also a long.
Let me see.
I think I didn't fill that trade.
The day after that trade.
Okay, let's play this out.
So we tagged in.
And tagged out.
And yeah.
That makes sense.
Okay. So does that count? Yeah. So this is cool.
So this is a New York continuation from London.
Part of interest is strong. Session is New York. Structure flow is void.
That is the only trade we've taken. I'm taking the trade.
No. So it has to be this trade.
The trend is.
Change your character.
Premium discount. No. News.
No.
Execution window.
9 to 10.
Playbook. Everything is followed.
Vamos.
Now let's do this one.
This is a London sweep Frank.
A empty leg in London.
The structure flow is trying to find a counter trend,
which I don't think actually matters.
Change of character pullback continuation.
This is a confined reversal.
It is in.
Premium discount.
There is no news.
The execution window was.
4 to 5 am.
Everything is on point.
Vamos. Okay.
For New York.
We have no news.
It's kind of one of them trades that I don't like again, isn't it?
So we've had the little sweep of London.
That's not a pullback.
Okay, so this is technically then.
Again, now I need to understand structure.
That's a change of character.
This is a change of character.
Okay, that's the actual shift.
Yeah, I'm trying to understand entry here.
Put it back to when the change of character actually happens.
So that's what price looks like.
Now I have to choose an entry.
Because the thing is like this should be theoretically protected
from buyers that step into the market
when New York session opens.
Not always, but it should be.
I don't think I shouldn't really trade below this lower game.
But what's the restore ward to the lock?
This is a little bit somewhat of an unorthodox position in some ways.
But the restore ward is there in abundance.
We have no news.
Okay, and even M5.
If you look at M5, the shift happens here.
Everything is mitigated.
All right, mitigated, mitigated.
The only thing that isn't mitigated is this.
Even the M3.
Yeah, it's not, it's not your easiest trade to take, but...
Let's see.
Actually, we know it takes in.
I know it should break some lot highs.
We don't know if that goes to break even though.
It's not break even.
That's break even.
The problem is...
It's like it's still a fair value up in here.
It's a break even because it is...
I don't want to say unorthodox because it's still a set up.
It's still everything is aligned.
It's just the entries a little bit not as simple as usual.
Maybe we get a break even and then just doesn't really matter.
Maybe it becomes a really well-managed trade.
Like, who knows, but I've managed it the best I could
in terms of how I think I would manage this in real time.
Nice.
This is what I mean as well, by the way.
If you remember the law, right, this specific set up,
this is the law sweep London, kind of continuation reversal.
I want this to happen at the beginning.
I want the sweep to take place and then trade.
This is something that the reason I added this is a set up
is because it's something that I see so many times.
I've seen this set up so many times where London finishes
and in this window we have a sweep and then New York reversal.
It's a schematic that plays out so many times.
I wanted to build a model on it.
The thing is the model has its edge when it sweeps like this
and then I'm trading it immediately, not when it sweeps it
and we come up in here and then New York does this
and then I'm trying to trade it from here.
The moves already happened.
If you notice, that's what I've been taking notes of.
It's like the model needs to be traded in a specific way.
I don't think we've already closed the position.
No, we haven't.
The rest of the position, I guess we can just leave it
to the swing highs.
It can maybe take some off here because just basically
expecting a reaction a little bit because you want to be out
of the position.
As an intraday trader, I personally, I don't like going
to sleep with positions open.
It's better when my stops are a break even and parties
have been taken and stuff, but holding positions
for multiple days, it starts to play with me because now
I'm in a bias.
Immediately, I don't care how good a trader you are.
If you're an intraday trader and you've taken a trade,
you now have the bias of wanting that trade to play out.
It may skew.
You might come in the next day and have a complete reset
and be like, "Actually, you know what?
I'm looking for shorts today because of X, Y, and Z, for example."
Maybe you've got a liquidity model with a different strategy.
I'm looking for shorts that day.
It starts skewing your mental.
So we'll see.
Cool.
Let's see if that break even helps us or not because I don't know.
I did say it's a bit of a weird one, but I would prefer
to just get my risk off the table.
Number one priority as a trader is protect your downside
because you can always figure out how to make money.
I would rather protect my downside than expose my downside
but hope to make money.
You can always make money.
You need to always protect your downside.
At least that's just me.
Maybe I'm just rubbing off my beliefs on you.
I don't know.
You can trade how you want, but for me, I'm risk averse.
I like my downside protected.
It makes me be able to trade better.
There's no reversal in there.
You can see it already.
But I trade better when my downside is protected.
It ends up being really good management, which doesn't surprise me,
but still I like my downside protected.
What is that?
Have we even taken a win in trade yet in August?
Oh, so I just begun.
Okay.
So we've got a little tiny buffer.
I also like to have, I like to start my months
with a little bit of a buffer.
It makes my trading so much better.
It's like trading on a cloud when I've had a couple of wins
or even just one good win.
One just 6% winner in the first week.
Ideally, like first few days, I will trade so much better that month.
Again, you can say what you want.
Be a robot.
Don't have emotions, but the reality is if you ever hear a trade
that psychology doesn't affect you, you just have to have a plan
and follow your rules.
It's like broke that guy's never tried trading with real capital.
Maybe, maybe he's profitable and demo.
But when it comes, when it comes to real money in your bank account,
it becomes a different ball game, man.
London sweep Asia.
Let's go to the general for the last trade.
I suppose premium discount.
Yeah, okay.
Point of interest is strong.
Wait, what am I doing?
The trade's here.
It's, yeah, what am I doing?
Okay, this is why I don't speak, by the way, but I'm doing this.
This is a long reversal.
It's from an empty leg.
Okay.
There's still no news apparently.
I really don't like that.
I'll take it anyway.
Maybe we get to break even.
But that's not a goodness sweep for me.
That's basically just equal laws.
But maybe we get to break even.
Again, my mindset is like, okay, cool.
But maybe we can get risk off.
Maybe we can get risk off.
So I'm looking at this invite to have all you got.
Again, it could put my stops here.
But for the purpose of this, I'm just in fact, you know what?
I won't put my stops here.
And I just know I've preached differently before and said like,
just cover the laws if you can.
But that was before I started understanding properly order flow.
This is a crazy expectation of a trade.
That technically estimates are very human.
But I have to reapply this order on.
At least we can have to break even.
Well, not break even, but at least we can remove like 0.7%.
Of risk.
Reduce 0.75% worth of risk.
Now, who knows? Maybe it plays out.
One to five is not so far away.
Oh, no, that is a good management.
Yeah, even the stop loss placement, like the details.
If it breaks this, it breaks out.
I don't mind that.
Again, good management, 0.25% loss, fine.
Point of interest is like strong technically.
I'm going to flag it for a view.
Okay.
Like it was such obviously it was such an obvious trap before.
This is why I would do this because, you know,
pre this, pre this level of in depth detail,
bearing in mind what you guys have to understand is like,
trade seller is a relatively new tool.
Like I've been using trades that I think for like seven,
six, seven months, maybe a little bit longer.
I think six months.
Something like that.
Maybe seven months, something like that.
But the back testing has only been out.
Now, I've been using trades a little bit longer than seven months,
but the back testing only came out like five months ago.
I've been using the back testing and the in depth,
like customization and stuff like that.
Like this is relatively new tool.
And so honestly, what this is able to do for your data and stuff is ridiculous.
Like this is all types of stuff you would have had to do before and manually in
Excel and stuff.
And it makes it so much harder.
So shout out more like what his building is.
It's an incredible one.
Really humble guy as well.
Nice guy.
Great trader.
Really cool guy.
Yeah, but yeah, the flag for review thing was a cool catch.
I wish I had that from the beginning because so many things like this,
for example, like in the live markets, there's no way that I would want to take
this trade,
but it's better to be able to stack evidence of when these certain setups
happen,
to be able to look at them and say like, okay, my data supports the fact that I
shouldn't do this.
My data supports the fact that I should do that.
Right.
The thing is, is like, just being a discretionary trader is,
I use this word a lot.
It's like, and I said it at the beginning, discretion in some sense can
basically be a crutch for laziness to some degree.
Because if something's discretionary, you could still basically define it in
some type of principle and test it.
And so I was making discretionary decisions because the reality is that our
brain is very,
especially when you take care of your brain and stuff as well.
People drastically overlook the mental health, not like going to the gym type
shit,
although that's great, like actual, like the brain as an organ itself, the gut
as an organ itself.
People don't realize that your gut is actually your largest brain to your gut
health, right?
Your actual mental health for your brain.
How important that sort of surface is because you're spending all this time in
the markets and like,
things are happening, you're storing this information in your brain.
That's why when it comes down to discretion, I say like, I can already see what
's going to happen.
It's not because I've got a magic ball or I'm in tune with the markets.
Although people call it that and I understand why.
It's because I've just seen it happen so many times that my brain literally
tells my entire rest of my body.
Like, hey, I've seen this.
I think I know how this plays out.
And then distinguishing between the amygdala screaming like,
hey, please get out of this trade and it's like, okay, why?
It's like, I just don't feel good.
That's, that's amygdala, that's psychology, that's fear.
But when you ask the question why and you get the answer that's logical,
which is does this, this, this, this, and this, I've seen this play out X
amount of times.
I know da, da, da, da, then it becomes rational.
But collecting the data on it, it just helps it more.
Okay, enough offline.
Did that not even break so long?
Okay.
At least it's a much better sweep.
So we're still long.
But at least it's a much better sweep.
Wednesday the 9th of August.
But yeah, Wednesday the 9th of August.
So really I need to see sweep of those age of lows, which is probably not going
to get.
Oh, an insertion.
So again, temp, we have inflation rates.
But I want to see a sweep of those Asian lows.
Nope.
New York, I'm going to get this in here.
Okay.
Ah, this is not one of those setups.
I just don't think I want to take it.
Oh, we have PPI.
I might be able to get away with it.
It's one of those setups where I know that my entry is going to be here,
even though technically price could easily come back down to here.
Again, remember I said, when I'm getting the lull, I want this lull,
and then I want to trade here, right?
Not here after it's already happened, which is this.
Because I know that price can easily trade back into this area.
But when the entry is here, then it's fine.
But I'll get away with it because we have PPI.
Like so?
Okay.
And...
Technically, the swing lull is here now because it broke a fracture.
Oh, man.
The environment that I would want to long this is if we have a really nice M15
sweep of this lull.
I do not want to long it without that, but it's impossible to do that anyway.
So it's cool.
See, a sweep like that is perfect, but it breaks.
It doesn't give us a shift in it.
It does give us a shift.
Oh, I would so take this trade in the live market.
I don't want to ski the day, though.
So I won't.
Hopefully, it doesn't tag in.
No, it doesn't.
That's good.
Perfect.
Thank you.
That makes this a swing high.
I would take that in the live market.
Obviously, there's no trade because price...
Yeah, we don't get an entry.
But I would take it if it did.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
This is where you need to check the structure.
I don't need to check past this because I understand that this is the lowest it
could possibly be.
And I get I don't need to look in here because I can visibly already see one
that has a three kind of puller.
And so then I know that we should perish here.
And so now what I can do, instead of just looking at every single of these
price legs,
I can come in here and see, okay.
I need to look at all this because I can see that this is the most recent one.
And then I just basically need to confirm whether that happens or not.
Then it does.
So then I know that that's the high.
Which I know then breaks this low, which breaks this high.
It breaks this high, it breaks this high.
Which...
doesn't break this high.
So I know that this lowers in control.
Perfect.
I don't know if that breaks that.
Or we're bearish, not bullish.
That'd be a great entry, wouldn't it?
So now I know that, for example,
that is not a pullback.
But that is a pullback.
But it doesn't break it.
So I can't short from here.
Let's just make sure...
32 candles.
I like the look of the setup, but what I can see is that it's from a weak point
of interest.
And I know so far from the data that the weak point of interest don't really
work well.
But I'd like to look at the setup objectively.
And would you look at that?
It doesn't work well.
458.
Again, another day you might end up getting that setup.
But these weak points of interest, they're not really doing so well.
That's much better.
What day is it? Choose a 15th.
We do have news.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, apologies.
If you choose at the 15th, we have...
We have ZEW retail sales.
Okay.
Probably no trade.
There's no reversal...
...until this low.
That would be a trade, but now we're 15 minutes away from retail sales.
Well, no, we don't.
We don't mind.
But a much better delivery of price.
Hmm, not long before we get the reversal.
Okay, and there's obviously not going to be a position for me in here.
I'll just take this out of 15.
Okay, interest in price delivery.
Okay.
Nope.
There's nothing there.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
It doesn't really matter though, does it?
It's not a trade here.
Okay, we take lows.
This becomes swing high, which I like and don't like at the same time.
It's now the 17th.
I like and don't like this high at the same time.
Because price is really moving nicely.
And therefore, I think that it's probably going to respect this high.
But it's what it is.
That's technically a change character.
We're not going to be up too long now.
It's in New York.
No, the age of lows didn't play.
I don't take trades when age of lows didn't play.
We're not going to take any trades.
London.
I knew it was going to do that.
Well, at least we are back to bearish.
This is a much nicer price range.
Friday 18th.
Okay.
London.
Need a London to sweep those eyes.
That's our swing high, which I really don't like.
Technically, we trade that.
I don't like this at all.
Equal highs across here.
Age of high up here.
I'll flag this for review in terms of trading obvious liquidity,
regardless of whether it trades in our favor or not.
But I'm going to need to check the M1 structure as well.
Because it's not clear at all.
We need to go all the way back.
Let's go all the way back to the M1.
Let's go for the M1.
Let's see if we can get a continuation.
We can definitely trade this.
We'll break that high.
Let's go for the M1.